Lúc này thì mới ở năm 2014, một nước lũ trên nhiều sông ghi nhận sư thế nước sốt,
tại gia lai đắt lắc hạnh hoa lập đồng, vì các bạn hết mưa các bạn còn một vài trạm tại đắt lắc vào hạnh hoa
còn 1 tương 1 mươi đến tảm mươi miếm emy lý mết.
Chính quyền từ chú hương đến cơ sở, các lực lượng vũ trang và đăng tiếp tục hình chường hủy động tổng lực,
để cứu chợ đồng bào, từ tiên cao nhất là tính mạng của người dân không để người dân bị đỏi bị giết.
Thì nhận lúc lúc, càng lộ dịnh thiếm nhiều khó khăn và mất mát của bà con, theo số liệu mới nhất về cơ sở này
từ bộ nông về phở mối chường đã có 1 trăm lình 2 người thiệt mạng và mất tích.
Hơn một nghiên 1 trong năm 2019, người mối trang tảm mấy sống nghiên cảm nhạm bị ngập.
Vì nông nghiệp, gần tảm mối nghiên hết tả lối, hòa mổ bị thiệt hại, hình 3, 2 chiệu còn ra súc ra cầm bị chết hoặc quân chôi,
thì 2 nặng hết và là tệ tắc lắc.